very excited to be here today to present
my dissertation research on expert
crowdsourcing which introduces
techniques for crowdsourcing complex
goals with flash teams and flash
organizations so for the next 45 minutes
or so I will show you how we can bring
together distributed experts from the
crowd within minutes and then enable
them to achieve large-scale complex
goals such as a condition I move over no
can you see okay such as software
development video production and product
and game design completing goals of this
nature used to require traditional teams
and organizational structures that were
composed of bounded employees or
contributors but over the last decade or
so the emergence of online labor
marketplaces has made it possible to
quickly bring together paid crowd
workers from around the world within
minutes to achieve a range of
large-scale tasks and while these online
marketplaces have started to change the
nature of how work gets done most of the
shifts have been for specific types of
goals and crowds specifically crops were
seeing has really focused on goals that
can be decomposed into homogenous micro
tasks that can then be achieved by
pretty much anyone regardless of their
expertise so for example not expert
crowds recruited from platforms like
Amazon Mechanical Turk are often tasked
with labeling images and translating
texts which are tasks that pretty much
anyone can do the problem with this
approach is that it does not easily
scale to larger open-ended and complex
goals such as the software development
and the video production goals that I
showed before when task minutes are
complex and interdependent you can't
really just decompose them into these
homogenous micro
tasks especially when they require a
certain level of expertise to complete
so as a result many real-world goals
that require significantly more
complexity expertise and coordination
between workers and requesters remain
out of reach for crowds so to drive
crowdsourcing past this complexity
boundary this thesis shifts away from
micro tasks work and introduces expert
crowds as a core component of
crowdsourcing systems expert crowds can
be recruited from many different online
marketplaces including up work
freelancer and 99designs for example up
work which is the focus of this work
allows clients to draw on a contingent
global labor pool by providing access to
millions of paid experts and
professionals with a variety of skills
including developers designers video
editors we've even hired musicians such
as an opera singer so but to achieve
complex and interdependent goals it's
not enough to just recruit these experts
from up work and then assume that just
because they have the skills needed to
achieve the tasks that they will be
successful in doing so complex work
requires coordination among individuals
with many different expertise which in
the case of crowd work also requires
coordinating interdependent workers who
are distributed around the globe and
have never worked together before easy
right so given these challenges
even though marketplaces like upwork
provide access to experts most
crowdsourcing research has focused on
completing tasks with non expert workers
so as a result expert crowd sourcing
currently lacks generalizable techniques
for guiding crowds through complex and
interdependent goals so this thesis
proposes that combining expert crowds
with comp
a tional techniques and organizational
structures can fill this gap and enable
crowds to achieve complex and
interdependent goals quickly reliably
and at scale alright so in this talk I
will present three projects which
introduce and evaluate two techniques
for creating team and organizational
structures composed of expert crowds and
these approaches are manifested in
foundry which is a computational
platform that we have created for
authoring crowd work structures and
managing interdependent crowd workers
the first project flash teams presents a
framework for dynamically assembling and
computationally managing crowd-sourced
expert teams in the second project I
show why the flash teams approach which
relies on predefined workflows won't be
sufficient for achieving large-scale and
open-ended goals that can't be
decomposed in advance then motivated by
this limitation the third project flash
organizations introduces a framework for
creating rapidly assembled and
reconfigurable organizational structures
that are composed of large groups of
expert crowd workers and then taken
together these projects reimagine a
future of work in which teams and
organizations are no longer anchored in
traditional labor models but are instead
fluidly assembled and reassembled from
globally networked labor markets and the
result of this vision is that is a
system that really empowers pretty much
anyone with an internet connection to
create and lead entire teams and
organizations that are composed of paid
crowd workers that can achieve complex
and open-ended goals all right so to
give you a sense of the road map for my
presentation I will first discuss each
of the three projects and we'll then
wrap up with a brief summary of the
contributions and the directions for a
future work
so the first project which Michael
mentioned before is titled expert
crowdsourcing with flash teams and we
presented this work at whist in 2014 in
this project we asked can we use the
large pool of expert crowd workers that
are available online to carry out
complex and interdependent goals if so
we could take advantage of the scale and
flexibility of the crowd but still take
on complex and interdependent work so
for example could we bring together a
team of crowd workers give them a napkin
sketch of an idea and then have them
create a user tested interactive web app
in a single day how about an animated
video in 48 hours or better yet could we
bring together multiple teams of crowd
workers to create an entire MOOC
platform along with content within a day
or two so our objective is to explore
the feasibility of solving complex and
interdependent goals such as the ones
that I just showed using structured
collaborations between experts from the
crowd as I mentioned before expert crowd
work is independent and uncoordinated
which makes it difficult to use crowds
to achieve complex and interdependent
goals we know from organizational
behavior research that even temporary
groups can coordinate complex work
effectively if they have lightweight
team scaffolds and these scaffolds
define who is working together and then
who is responsible for which task and so
our goal here is to combine the
strengths of Team scaffolds with the
scale interactivity of computation to
dynamically assemble and manage teams of
expert crowd workers to do this we
introduced flash teams which are
computationally guided teams of crowd
experts that are supported by
lightweight reproducible and scalable
team
structures project requesters assemble
and manage a flash team by training
blocks together to transform a starter
input into a desired final output the
complete set of blocks determines which
crowd experts need to be recruited and
when they're likely to be needed and
each block is a self-contained
reusable representation that has
computational properties so requires the
skills needed an input target duration
instructions and an output type so for
example suppose that you're a project
requester and you're building a team to
execute the user centered design process
starting from a napkin sketch of an idea
that you may have you might connect the
lo-fi mock-ups from the first block to
any other block that takes Lofa mock-ups
as input such as a revised mock-up block
or a heuristic evaluation block so to
put this into context here you can see
with this flash teams complete sequence
of blocks and inputs and outputs might
look like alright so because these flash
teams are machine readable we can create
entirely new kinds of organizational
forms that enable these teams to be
replicated recombined it can grow and
shrink be optimized and more for example
because flash teams benefit from
modularity they can be replicated and
used for many different types of
projects another benefit of modularity
is that these teams can be combined
almost like Lego blocks to create much
larger organizations flash teams also
benefit from elastic growth which
enables them to grow and shrink as
needed
flash teams can be pipelined
rather than waiting for the entire task
to complete and this allows computation
to automatically optimize these teams
and finally we can automatically create
new teams ones that may have never even
existed before
using the components of previous teams
okay so existing project management and
micro test management tools really don't
capitalize on the scale and affordances
of distributed expert crowd work and so
this means that flash teams require new
kinds of tools and infrastructure and so
as part of this research we've created
foundry which is a web platform that is
designed to organize coordinate and
manage distributed expert crowds foundry
allows project requesters to create
flash team structures and also allows
team members to track their progress and
send notifications when handoffs have
been issued with foundry requesters can
either create a flash team from scratch
or they can compose or modify previous
team structures from the foundry flash
teams library so to give you a sense of
how foundry works let's create another
user centered design napkin sketch team
so as a requester you would first add
the team roles by reaching into nearly
2500 upwork skill categories you would
then add blocks to the timeline similar
to how you would on a calendar interface
including all the data around members
inputs and outputs you can make
dependencies visible by explicitly
marking tasks that connect by explicitly
marking tasks based on their inputs and
their outputs when each block is
complete workers upload their output
materials to the Google Drive folder for
the project which boundary automatically
generates and then if two blocks occur
at the same time so here the hi-fi
prototype and the logo design should be
working together you can indicate that
these blocks should be in synchronous
collaboration right so once you've
created your team and you've recruited
your workers from up work you would
click the start button on foundry to
enter runtime mode and runtime mode
foundry adds a timer to each task in the
timeline and then each worker on your
team will receive a unique link that
logs them into the
run time with their tasks highlighted in
the timeline so here you can see that
they're all highlighted in yellow the
lo-fi mock-ups and the revised lo-fi
mock-ups and then when a worker starts a
task the timer for the task begins if a
task is delayed or it's completed early
foundry will recalculate the start time
for the subsequent tasks update the
timeline and then notify workers when a
worker marks block is complete foundry
notifies workers for the next block that
their task is now active so in order to
better understand the design space of
flash teams and really what they would
enable us to do we recruited experts
from up work and then I ran a series of
example projects ranging from design to
education so here you can see
screenshots of all the team deliverables
that I'm about to describe the first
series of projects that we ran was with
the napkin sketch design team and we
gave three different flash teams
sketches that we took from three
different Stanford student assignments
in the introduction to HCI class which
I'm sure some people in here have taken
hopefully and their goal was to produce
a fully functional user tested web
prototype so it's shown in the table on
the slide here the completion times
ranged from 18 hours to 31 hours and 30
minutes depending on the amount of
pipelining and elasticity and all of the
outputs were fully functional and
reflected the original intent so after
completing the napkin sketch design
teams we asked ourselves who flash team
support creative outputs and non
engineering domains to test this we
decided to use a flash team to create an
animated video that was based on a rough
script idea which was to celebrate the
retirement of Terry Winograd which as
many of you here hopefully know was one
founders of the Stanford HCI group and a
professor in the computer science
department here at Stanford for many
many years and so as shown in the slide
we recruited a director and animator
sound gen sound engineer script writer
and illustrator all from up work and
then in under two days the flash team
came up with the plot and produced the
video which captured a funny anecdote
from Terry's childhood when he built a
computer in his garage so let's have a
look at the video that the flash team
produced
it's the future
it works all right so the napkin sketch
designed him and then the animation team
that you just saw demonstrated that this
flash team's approach to expert crowds
were seeing works and so our third
objective was to combine multiple
modular team structures to create a new
online learning MOOC platform and to
generate three short lessons we added
one more education flash team and then
replicated and combined the teams to
create a much larger organization for
each course one education team created
the course content and the quiz
materials and then one animation team
produced the video simultaneously three
napkin sketch teams worked on the web
platform that was used to upload and
share the courses taken together it took
the nine flash teams 19 hours and 20
minutes to create the MOOC platform and
to generate the three interactive
lessons and you can see excerpts from
each of the three courses on the bottom
of the slide right so in this project we
had one final question does this
infrastructure actually help people
collaborate so we conducted a controlled
experiment to compare flash teams to a
self-managed teams approach or the
experts choose their own path we
collected data with three napkin sketch
design teams in each condition totaling
22 crowd experts from up work we asked
all of the teams to create a simple
party planning task manager from an
input sketch and the main difference
between the conditions was the existence
of the flash teams workflow which define
the sequences of tasks to team members
and support them support coordination
via handoffs and notifications while all
six of the team's completed the project
the flash teams took roughly half as
many work hours which means half the
cost
they also followed the iterative design
process
more closely they required half as much
communication as well as less
coordination and in fact by active work
time even the slowest / team completed
the project faster than the fastest team
in the control condition and I explore
and discuss some of the qualitative
insights from this project in my next
project
alright so to summarize most
crowdsourcing research has focused on
coordinating workers that are homogenous
and replaceable
in contrast flashings offer an
opportunity to shift the crowdsourcing
narrative towards teams of diverse
experts from the crowd right so moving
on to the second project the first
project demonstrated that computational
work structures such as crowdsourcing
workflows can enable expert crowds to
achieve complex and interdependent goals
we noticed however that when things went
wrong or workers had ideas that they
wanted to explore the flash teams were
constrained by the specifications that
were embedded in their workflows so for
example in the follow-up survey some of
the workers express frustration with all
of their tasks being pre-planned
which they felt really minimize their
need to communicate and coordinate with
other workers and also prevented them
from making changes and exploring other
ideas so despite the successes of the
flash teams that I just presented these
challenges point to some potential
limitations of crowdsourcing workflows
so if we hope to achieve our vision for
expert crowd work it's critical that we
understand the strengths and limitations
of crowdsourcing workflows given this
objective in this project we asked how
do crowdsourcing workflows such as those
used by the flash teams support and
constrain complex crowd work to answer
this question we conducted in-depth case
studies of the six teams of crowd
workers in the field experiment that we
completed in the flash teams project for
conceptual reasons we
labeled the flash teams as workflow
based teams and the self-managed teams
as role based teams as a reminder all of
the teams were composed of three roles
including a UX researcher a UI designer
and a developer the key difference
between the conditions was that the
workflow based teams enacted pre
specified workflows that decomposed and
predefined all tasks and dependencies in
contrast the role based teams enacted
minimally specified work plans which
were just one long unstructured task
that was assigned to all three of the
workers so our analysis here aims to
understand how the workflow based and
the role based teams enacted and adapted
their work structures as well as the
challenges that they encountered the
data that informs this analysis includes
a mix of chat logs survey data
observation notes and other archival
data including all of the foundry team
data the up work work diary data and all
of the task deliverables to analyze the
data I used an open-ended inductive
coding process using in vivo and during
the initial round of coding I identified
common behaviors practices and
challenges that were encountered in each
of the team's next I compared the themes
and that emerged across the teams and
conditions to develop conceptual
insights and as I was doing this I was
constantly going back to the literature
on coordination and workflows to further
refine the codes and then once the
qualitative analysis was complete I
analyzed the work diary data from up
work to better understand really what
might explain the differences that we
were seeing so in line with prior
research on coordination and
organizational design our analysis
reveals that neither pre-specified
workflows nor minimally specified work
plans are fully sufficient for
orchestrating complex and interdependent
crowd goals goals of this nature require
coordinating multiple interdependent
contributions from diverse workers and
adapting work structure
and deliverables in response to
unplanned contingencies and
opportunities that emerge along the way
so this suggests that for crowds to take
on complex goals crowdsourcing workflows
really need to support both coordination
and adaptation now at a high level a
results show that crowdsourcing
workflows support coordination but they
inhibit adaptation in contrast the
minimally specified work plans are
easier to adapt but they make
coordination more difficult and they
really don't ensure that the best
adaptations are the ones that are
pursued so I'll now briefly demonstrate
how the workflows supported coordination
and will then show how they inhibit
adaptation the pre-specified workflows
encoded best practices and the teams
which helped ensure that the workers
didn't make obvious missteps
they also clarified the order in the
relationship of the tasks which reduce
the amount of explicit coordination and
communication that was needed between
the workers in contrast the role based
teams had to decide amongst themselves
how to proceed and this often led to
inefficient coordination and even
incorrect work all right so to
understand really how the workers
enacted their work structures and the
extent to which they encoded best
practices we use the up work work diary
data to reconstruct a timeline of what
happened in each of the teams so the
timelines that you see here are group by
team and each of the rows represents a
role and then each of the blocks
represent a continuous period of time
that was logged by the worker in that
role and so what you see here is that
all of the workflow based teams
completed the same set of tasks in the
same order by workers in the same role
in contrast the role based teams all
enacted vastly different work plans
they also adopted much more concurrent
work structures as you can see these
blocks overlap across the rows much more
and so this resulted in workers
completing tasks in different orders and
at different times sometimes working
simultaneously and other times working
independently so what this tells us is
that by decomposing goals into
actionable tasks with clear outputs and
constraints the workflows helped orient
and integrate the actions in the team
which led to more consistent and
replicable outcomes and finally it also
became clear that the pre-specified
workflows help minimize coordination
challenges in the teams in contrast the
role based teams encountered many more
coordination challenges so for example
one of the teams spent two hours arguing
over their responsibilities which led to
the developer getting fired and then
replaced it and then the workers also
started to work without first
communicating with their team members
and in some cases they even completed
their tasks without notifying dependent
team members so I'll now demonstrate how
the workflows inhibited the teams from
adapting it became clear in our analysis
that the rigid structure that was
imposed by the workflows made it
difficult for the teams to respond to
contingencies and prevented crowd
workers from pivoting when better
opportunities emerged a results show how
the teams responded to different types
of contingencies and here we're defining
contingencies as unexpected challenges
or occurrences that prevented these work
plans from proceeding in this talk I
will discuss one type of contingency
which was incompatible deliverables in
our data the incompatible deliverables
were caused by workers deliberate
decisions such as know deciding to use a
different programming language than the
one
that we had explicitly requested as well
as errors and incorrect assumptions and
in almost all of these cases regardless
of how detailed you had made the
workflow these contingencies and
incompatible deliverables were difficult
to predict a priori and so given the
rigid structure that was imposed by the
workflows the workflow based teams were
unable to respond in a in response we
had trouble adapting when these
incompatible deliverables and
contingencies occurred so as a result
workers ultimately had to accept the
deliverables as is and just move on and
since the workflows were unable to
detect most of these decisions and
assumptions and errors as they were
happening the incompatible deliverables
really went unnoticed until the tasks
were completed so for example as shown
in the chat excerpt here on the slide
one of the UX researchers incorrectly
assumed that it would be okay to use his
own opinion and judgment when conducting
the heuristic evaluation instead of
using Nielsen's usability heuristics and
this worker decided to only reveal this
assumption to his team members once he
had already completed the task and by
that point you know the changes that
were required were outside the bounds of
what the workflows could support which
prevented these teams then from adapting
in contrast the concurrent and the
emergent work structures that were
adopted by the role based teams were
able to cut these because of this the
teams were able to catch these missing
deliverable details and
incompatibilities as they were happening
and therefore before they were it was
too late for example when one of the UI
designers finished the mock-ups the UX
researcher quickly reviewed them before
conducting the heuristic evaluation and
in this review the UX
researcher noticed that the mock-ups
were missing error messages for
incomplete form fields which then
allowed the UI designer to quickly go
back and fix the mock-ups before the UX
researcher conducted the heuristic
evaluation in addition to facing
contingencies all of the teams faced
situations in which their work
structures or plans really weren't best
suited for their local context or their
current situation and when these
mismatches occurred the role based teams
could adapt their work plans whereas the
workflow based teams were bound to the
specifications that were embedded in
their workflows so for example in
attempt to minimize delays that were
caused by the UI designer not showing up
the developer in one of the workflow
teams wanted to work in parallel but was
ultimately unable to revise the work
structure and just had to wait in
contrast the role based teams would
internally establish informal deadlines
and then adapt them as needed so for
example when time was running out the
teams adapted their work structures by
prioritizing the key tasks and then
collaborating to make sure that they got
done the crowd workers also attempted to
improve their mobile web apps by
pursuing alternative opportunities such
as adding new features that they felt
were important the workflow based teams
however were limited by the predefined
work structures and the constraints that
were embedded in these workflows and so
as a result all of their attempts to add
new features such as their attempts to
add search delete pagination and sort
features were all unsuccessful in
contrast while the role based teams
attempted to add fewer features they
were much more successful in doing so so
to conclude this project sheds light on
some of the reasons why crowds trouble
with complex work our findings suggests
that while crowdsourcing workflows are
important coordination artifacts they
stimula crowd workers ability to adapt
in response to unplanned
engine sees or opportunities that might
emerge and given that it is impossible
to predict all possible contingencies
and adaptations crowdsourcing workflows
are in the in their current form at
least are fundamentally incompatible
with complex goals so taken together
these results suggest that there's
really no such thing as a perfect
workflow for complex crowd work
crowdsourcing workflows need to take
into account both the attributes and the
uncertainty of the task and the
environment which few workflows
currently do and finally these results
also surface in interesting workflow
paradox
so by preventing bad outcomes such as
coordination challenges our results show
that workflows and these formal
coordination structures are also
preventing good outcomes and desirable
adaptations alright so moving on to the
third and final project as we saw in the
first project the flash teams
demonstrated that we can crowdsource
complex and interdependent goals but as
we saw in the last project the
pre-specified workflows that were used
by the flash teams struggle to scale to
goals that can't be defined in advance
and so motivated by this insight in this
last project we asked whether we can
crowdsource goals that are complex and
evolving by evolving we're referring to
goals that are loosely defined and can't
be decomposed in advance goals that are
loosely defined and evolving are not
easily adapted for crowdsourcing unlike
goals that are completed by micro tasks
workers and the flash teams open-ended
goals such as invention and Production
Engineering are all difficult to
articulate modular eyes and pre specify
all of the possible actions that are
needed to achieve them in contrast
traditional organizations regularly
orchestrate large groups in
pursuit of very open-ended goals so
unlike existing crowdsourcing
infrastructures organizations coordinate
work by arranging employees into a set
of formal organizational structures such
as roles teams and hierarchies and these
structures and code responsibilities
interdependencies and information flow
but they do not necessarily articulate
and pre specify all of the sequences of
actions that are needed to achieve them
so in order to achieve similarly
open-ended goals with crowds we explore
an alternative crowd sourcing approach
that combines organizational structures
with computational crowd sourcing
techniques to create flash organizations
flash organizations are rapidly
assembled and reconfigurable
organizational structures that are
composed of large groups of online crowd
workers to achieve complex and
open-ended goals flash organizations
computationally instantiate roles teams
and hierarchies they populate these
structures on demand by issuing open
calls to experts and paid crowd sourcing
market places such as up work and the
flash organizations can then reconfigure
these structures to responsibly adapt
the organization's activity which
enables orchestrated efforts towards
open-ended goals so here's an example of
a flash organization structure the
organization is composed of many
different roles which are nested into
teams which are then nested under the
organization's leader and as I'm about
to show you the roles teams and
hierarchy that make up the flash
organization structure are
computationally instantiated populated
and reconfigured using foundry which you
had seen before so foundry represents a
flash organization as a set of
hierarchically nested roles which it
then uses for open call hiring from the
crowd and it also uses it to execute the
tasks as you'll see in a second an each
role in two
it's a position for a crowd worker
specifies the expertise needed to fill
the position and then assigns the
rolling level and the organization's
hierarchy boundary populates the
organizational structures using
automated on-demand hiring the way that
this works is that when a user adds a
new task to the timeline boundary
immediately begins the hiring process
for the necessary positions to complete
that task so boundary initiates the
hiring process by emailing qualified
workers to notify them that a new
position that requires their skills is
available on a first-come first-served
basis the first worker to click on the
link in the email has ten minutes to
read the details of the task and then
choose whether to accept it and start
working and others remain in the queue
in case that first worker declines the
organization and the team leaders also
have the option to manually higher
specific workers and then assign them to
a role when a worker accepts a task
Foundry launches an interactive
onboarding tour that provides them with
a description of the organization's
goals as well as their individual tasks
nem foundry enables reconfiguration of
organizational structures using a branch
and merge technique that is inspired by
distributed version control and this
technique essentially decouples the
current state of the code from any
proposed edits then foundry adapts this
model to enact both top-down
organizational changes as well as
bottom-up changes that are driven by the
workers and any member of the
organization can branch the current
organizational structure make any
desired edits and then issue a pull
request for review by one of the
organization's leaders who can then
decide whether to merge it in to the
ongoing organization all right so here
you can see two screenshots of how
foundry displays changes in a pull
request the left screenshot shows the
current organizational
structure and then the right screenshot
shows the proposed change requests which
in this case shows a task that was added
in orange and then a task that was
erased in white and any organizational
structure within foundry can be edited
this includes changes to roles teams the
hierarchy and tasks okay so to evaluate
whether flash organizations can in fact
achieve large-scale and open-ended goals
we conducted three proof-of-concept
experiments we recruited three leaders
from outside of our research team gave
them a budget and then allowed them to
create and lead a flash organization
using foundry over the course of six
weeks all of the workers were recruited
from up work and the three organizations
each of which I'll show you in a moment
spanned across software product and game
design the first organization EMS trauma
report was designed and led by a medical
resident and this organization used the
crowd to create a functional prototype
of an Android mobile and web application
that allowed EMS workers to report a
trauma injury from an ambulance on their
way to the hospital
the web application also supported
accessing and managing the trauma cases
so here you can see some of the
screenshots from the mobile web and the
mobile app and the web app as well as a
marketing video that the crowd had
produced the second organization true
story was designed and led by a team of
crowdfunded card game makers and this
organization used the crowd to design
manufacture and play test a storytelling
card game as well as an accompanying
mobile and web application the crowd
designed and produced 280 card decks
with story prompts as well as an app for
recording the stories and a web app for
downloading and sharing the story
recordings and finally the third
organization Enterprise Workshop
planning portal was designed and led by
an employee of an advanced technology
labs group within a large software
consulting group
and this organization use the crowd to
create an enterprise IT portal to
administer client workshops so here are
the final organizational structures for
the three organizations in total the
organization's collectively comprise
ninety three crowd workers including 22
team leads and 24 teams EMS trauma
report the first organization there had
the most diverse team structures and was
the most complex out of the
organization's true story was the
flattest organization meaning that it
had the fewest team leads and the
Enterprise Portal organization had that
had the fewest teams and the teams were
relatively large compared to the other
organization and so taken together the
93 crowd workers completed 639 tasks
across a total of three thousand two
hundred and sixty-one person hours of
work time the median tasks across the
organizations lasted a little bit over
three hours and all the organization's
completed the work within 46 days the
organization on team leads utilize how
boundaries automated hiring
functionality to fill 75 new roles in
the organization structure using up work
and so as you can see here are the
hiring times for each of the three
organizations and across all three of
them
the median hiring time was 13 minutes
and 40 seconds which is extremely fast
in contrast manual hiring from the up
work marketplace required a median of
nearly 15 hours and in total the
organization's fill 20 roles with manual
hires and just for context traditional
organizations take between 14 and 25
days to hire which is obviously much
longer and so during each of the
projects the organization's continuously
adapted to Oh
yes was there way to check the quality
of higher so we didn't go into this and
you know what we created these panel
shanks of questions now and their mama
so we created panels for the different
roles that we thought would be needed
and we interviewed and gave them starter
tasks in advance in order to join that
panel and then once they were on the
panel any task that required the skills
that had been screened for on that on
the panel where it was then used so
that's where we sent the emails to so
panels were associated with roles does
that answer your question yeah I'm just
thinking like further down the road
let's say if you try to take like a
month of work of someone who was hired
by automated learning versus manual
Aaron was he like a better employee may
be the manual hires tended to be more
like team leads or perfect people with
excessive excused where you really
wanted to screen and we even talk more
about it later
but I think that would be an interesting
analysis to run for sure so yeah so
during each of the projects the
organization's work continuously adapted
to the changing conditions by adding and
revising people task teams and time and
in total the organization submitted five
hundred and sixty six pull request
changes with an average of four point
five pull requests per day per
organization and while the breakdown of
requests by source varied across the
organizations on average twenty two
point four percent of the requests came
from the workers 68.2% came from the
team leads and nine percent came from
the organization's leaders so as you can
see the changes here to the
organizational structure we're both
top-down for the leaders directive and
then bottom up for the workers
initiative so here you can see in this
very large table a summary of the
outcomes that I just described all of as
these results demonstrate all three of
the organization's
successfully achieved their goals and
furthermore all three of the final
deliverables passed a quality review
from from different neutral expert
reviewers that we had found to review
these applications and in terms of cost
the cheapest organization was true story
which came out to six thousand six
hundred and fifty dollars and the most
expensive organization was EMS trauma
report which came out to six she came
out to forty six thousand one hundred
and ninety dollars which is much more um
so to wrap this up in this paper we
demonstrated a technique that combines
computational organizational structures
with the on-demand networked global
workforce to produce organizations that
can grow shrink and rearrange themselves
in real time flash organizations advance
a future of work that is increasingly
mediated by computation and algorithms
and open a set of goals that up until
now have really been out of reach to
crowdsourcing okay so I'd now like to
wrap up with a brief summary and
discussion of the contributions as well
as the directions for future work so to
summarize this thesis shifts away from
crowd work that relies on homogeneous
micro tasks workers instead we introduce
interdependent teams and reconfigurable
organizations that are composed of
expert crowd workers specifically we
present three projects which combine
literature theories and methods from
organizational behavior human-computer
interaction and computer science and
through these three projects and this
interdisciplinary approach we introduced
and evaluated a novel combination of
expert crowds organizational structures
and computational techniques for
completing highly complex and
interdependent goals which have been out
of reach to crowds collectively these
three projects help inform the design
and the general understanding of of
crowdsourcing technique
and computational systems at both the
team and the organization level and more
broadly this research makes
contributions to crowd computing system
design and organizational design first
this thesis introduces expert crowds as
a core component of crowd sourcing
systems and specifically flash teams and
flash organizations contribute to
computational approaches for
coordinating expert crowd work and these
approaches expand the capabilities of
paid crowd work and crowd computing by
enabling complex and open-ended goals
second our computational platform
foundry contributes a new crowd sourcing
system that's capable of authoring and
orchestrating a range of complex
crowd-sourced goals so to our knowledge
foundry represents the first
computational authoring and coordination
platform for interdependent expert crowd
work and furthermore the insights from
the flash team and the flash
organizations deploy the deployments
with both of which used foundry
contribute to the design space as well
as our understanding of computational
crowd sourcing systems and techniques
finally this thesis also advances
research on organizational design flash
games and flash organizations represent
the first examples of computational
systems and frameworks that encode and
reconfigure temporary role-based
coordination structures that are capable
of achieving complex and interdependent
efforts online and so this thesis really
envisions a world in which work can
occur online by experts who have never
worked together before
flash teams and organizations serve as
initial examples of this vision but they
also open up several interesting
opportunities for future work first
given that most complex goals can't be
completely pre specified in advance and
that it's pretty much impossible to
predict all of the possible
contingencies that might occur
along the way future work really needs
to explore approaches for supporting
flexible work structures and emergent
coordination while making sure to
maintain the scale and affordances of
computation second most existing
marketplaces really were not designed
around interdependent expert crowd work
and as a result they have critical
limitations including hiring transaction
costs and search frictions similarly
most existing coordination tools such as
saunas Skype Basecamp and slack which
I'm sure many people in this room
including myself use were not we're not
designed to integrate with crowdsourcing
marketplaces and we're definitely not
designed to support short-term yet
complex crowd work so while platforms
like foundry begin to fill this gap
there's really a big opportunity for
researchers to design new types of
marketplaces and coordination tools that
are centered around interdependent and
on-demand expert crowd work finally
flash teams and organizations suggest
important research directions for
traditional teams and organizations so
for example many large or distributed
organizations could view their own
employees as a crowd and then convene
them using these computational
techniques on demand questions and
organizations also introduced the
opportunity for new types of hybrid
teams and organizations that are
composed of both internal crowds and
internal crowds like their employees and
external crowds from these marketplaces
and so for example you can imagine a
start-up supplementing their founding
team with additional expertise from the
crowd as their as the needs of the
organization evolve or you can imagine a
large organization supplementing their
project teams with expertise that they
don't currently have available
internally all right so I'd quickly like
to wrap up with some thank-yous I would
first like to thank all of the
organizations that have funded this work
especially the Stanford
interdisciplinary graduate fellowship
I'd also like to thank all of my amazing
collaborators that have contributed to
this work it really would not have been
possible without this incredible team I
would like to of course thank all of the
up work workers who participated in this
research because we learned a ton fir'd
from them and we hope that this work
ultimately builds a brighter future of
work and opens new opportunities for
them next I'd like to acknowledge and
thank the WTO MS&E and HCI research
communities as well as the staff for
their support and their friendship over
the last five years and most importantly
I'd like to thank my advisors and my
committee
Michael Melissa and Pam for their
ongoing support feedback and guidance at
times I really wasn't the easiest
student to advise giving my
interdisciplinary interests as Michael
mentioned before but the three of them
really worked together to support me
along the way so thanks to the three of
you always really able to achieve my
goal of conducting research across
organizational behavior and HCI so I'm
really appreciative for everything that
you've taught me and everything you
helped me achieve I'd also like to thank
Jeff Hancock and James who are taking
the time to be here and for agreeing to
be on my examining committee and finally
I'd like to thank my fiance Andrew who
is here today for his unconditional love
and encouragement and for listening to
countless practice talks uh-huh and
finally I wanna thank my parents and my
sister who couldn't be here today for
all their love and their support and
patience over the last 27 years so
that's all I have and I am now happy to
take questions
[Applause]
convening the closed session yeah I
found this absolutely fascinating
because I've spent tens of thousands of
dollars on a pork and I read like 40 to
50 freelancers wrong work so I was
wondering if you're gonna plan to take
boundary to market like try to be gonna
start up yeah so right now we are
working on developing it for a more of
like a public launch not necessarily a
startup but we get emails a lot from
researchers some companies that want to
use it and so we are trying to make it
from you know transfer it from a
research platform that we designed for
ourselves to a tool that other people
can use and we'll send out an email to
the group when that is done we're hoping
for the one ish by the end of the
quarter so keep you posted at the end
about sort of self adaptation so random
question you got like a ton of money and
you could throw some kind of machine
learning F at this some part of the
adaptation and stuff like any part of
the sort of last bit of the system
you're talking about what do you
wouldn't imagine me to do with it or
what using creative ways thinking start
thinking about so it's a good question
we got your thought a lot about it as we
think about the next steps for this and
I think one of the most interesting
areas in that space is like
automatically generating these workflows
and helping them adapt along the way so
one idea that I had the other day was
you could imagine having something like
ways like which you know adapts your
directions as you go based on
crowd-sourced data and so you could
imagine having something like that for
these workflows where it would kind of
suggest different tasks based on what's
happening of a task is delayed or maybe
you need additional work or you would
imagine there being like different paths
after each task that it could then
suggest a asleep that doesn't work as we
saw it can't be too constrained
then you could kind of come up with your
own path but I think that helping people
kind of guide the workers and create
these workflows is a is a big area for
machine learning but to do that we would
need not even as much money but we would
need data and so we would need to run a
lot of these to really understand what
what should happen having the same
mistakes that might have been
inefficient to be more detail yeah so
that's a good question I think right now
I mean that's probably one of the you
know limitations of this approach like
if you're trying to build a very long
term project that has a lot of embedded
institutional knowledge you would
probably want people who are around for
the whole time whereas this approach is
better for something with more of like a
starting and end point but having said
that we built some stuff into foundry to
help encode some of that knowledge so
each of the tasks have documentation
questions that workers need to answer
along the way in order to like complete
their tasks and then when a new worker
comes in part of that onboarding process
that I showed is that they have to
review that documentation and then we
also integrate foundry which I didn't
show with slack and so all of that data
and all that information is also there
but you could imagine you know making
the system smarter and showing that
knowledge in different ways but it's a
good question of obviously limitation
full sense so that they might be
reusable in other words you start
creating components of parts that might
be reused again and that in a Futurecast
yeah so I have two responses to that one
is that I think the marketplaces
themselves could almost do a better job
of like creating these teams and like
showing you which people have worked
together so you could almost hire them
together and know if our who's here is
doing some work on that it's an offer
here
but yet we have there are students who
are working on that idea and then the
other thing is that I didn't show it
here but a lot of the workers were
rehired so if a request or a team lead
had a good experience with a worker they
would just rehire them for the next task
so you don't always have to hire new
workers for tasks you can take people
that you've worked with before and I
think over time you could imagine
optimizing this on-demand hiring process
to take that into account in scaffold is
[Music]
yeah so team scaffolds which is
Melissa's research who she's on my
committee essentially showed that these
role based team structures could be like
just biting roles on a team that can be
it will help these teams coordinator
workers themselves don't actually need
to have as much experience to say
working together but because they have
experience with that role those roles
help define their responsibilities and
that allows them to then work together
and so we took that with flesh teams and
we said well we have all these crowd
workers that are available online and we
know you know generally what the roles
that are needed to to complete these
goals are so it didn't matter like
exactly which worker filled that role as
long as that they had the skills and so
that's kind of how we took inspiration
from Team scaffolds into flash teams and
then in foundry as you saw you add the
roles and then you also add I don't know
if it was in the screenshot that I
showed but you also add the skills that
are needed for that role and so that
helps them to find the kind of the
requirements for that person and those
roles are then assigned to the tasks
that they're responsible for which kind
of defines their responsibilities and
even if they haven't worked together
before they know what their requirements
are and they know
and what the responsibilities of the
rest of their team is and then this
definitely transferred over to to the
flash organizations and so there we are
trying to coordinate much larger goals
of people who had never work together
before and so there there's this term of
asset specificity where workers over
time develop establish like
collaboration patterns and they can
become much more efficient which is I
guess getting to your question before
and so they're the roles also help with
that challenge so it definitely was a
big part of all of this work